[Music]
madam president madam and
gentlemen Heads of State and Government
Excellencies ladies and gentlemen my
thoughts go first to the people
who were carried away by clerk 19 and
to their families plunged in
sadness
they also go to  the one who is
still fighting against this scourge that strikes them
I would also like to
warmly thank the many people
who every day invest in the fight
against this virus
their action has been decisive for a
few weeks our lives have
changed radically and from
successive upheavals to  this
pandemic will inevitably
continue is up to us to
ensure that the difficulties of amenities
and even the current suffering
lead us to draw new
perspectives through the
considerable socio-economic changes that they
entail this crisis must encourage us
to show more solidarity
it is a moral imperative it is a
collective interest a social  lasting global solution
the pandemic depends largely on the
development and rapid deployment
of effective vaccine diagnostics and treatment
without them every country in the
world remains vulnerable
it is therefore vital to ensure equitable access for all
to
essential medical technologies in the fight
against the virus
to  succeed alone a coordinated
and united response will be crowned with success
this inevitably implies the
mobilization of financial resources
on a global scale so that we
can quickly develop and
deploy treatment diagnostic tools
and an effective vaccine
accessible to all populations
responding to  the appeal of an
unprecedented
global coalition of the world health organization
i welcome the initiative of the
european union which wished to join
forces with those of
international actors from the public private sectors
and civil society to
organize  this donors' conference
our responsibility  é is to act
now collectively and
effectively
we have always held our place in the
concert of nations in the
humanitarian fields where
international solidarity is manifested more than
ever
I wish to join my voice to those of
the international community this is the
reason for  which the principality of
monaco solidaire is committed today to
contributing to this common effort I am
convinced that it is only
together that we will be able to overcome this
ordeal which in our recent history
has no equivalent together  and united
we will also have the opportunity
to direct the future towards a more
sustainable and more inclusive path
I know I can count on the
mobilization of all thank you